francia sigue atónita tres días después
del asesinato de esa miel para ti un
profesor de 47 años profesor de historia
de un colegio que fue víctima es la
víctima mortal de un nuevo atentado
terrorista aquí en francia los
sindicatos de profesores hicieron un
llamado nacional para que las personas
salieran a rendirle un homenaje a este
profesor y miles dijeron sí miles
dijeron estar presentes en varias
ciudades del país y aquí en parís en la
plaza de la república miles de personas
se congregaron en la tarde de este
domingo trayendo velas trayendo mensajes
de apoyo a la miel para ti pero también
a la educación nacional por ejemplo
varios de las personas que estuvieron
acá que no solamente eran familias
enteras sino también profesores algunos
jubilados no se contaron porque para
ellos era importante venir hoy hasta acá
importante venir aquí para apoyar a los
profesores y también a nuestros hijos
serán los niños los portadores de la luz
de la enseñanza pública más de mi hija
es profesora yo fui estudiante de la
escuela de la república y quiero que mi
nieto continúe gozando de esta escuela
libre en la que todos los hombres son
iguales y en la que la fraternidad se
pone en marcha es muy importante estar
aquí y continuar defendiendo estos
valores es por eso que estoy aquí por
hace posee gestión precisamente se va a
ser ahora la tarea del gobierno nacional
saber cómo defender la educación
nacional y también cómo proteger a los
profesores que son víctimas de ataques y
de amenazas por las enseñanzas que dan
en las escuelas públicas por ahora se
sabe que este próximo miércoles emanuel
al marco decidirá un homenaje nacional
hacia miel para chicos